I built my name is Yuri my question is
about giving some chance to the chance
the probability of winning a lottery is
very very small nevertheless is playing
lottery rational thanks the lottery
Yuri Yuri Yuri I've got to tell you when
I first I doesn't sound like you're in
the u.s. I grew up in the US and I lived
in Seattle Washington for a while now
Washington in the United States is a
Western state has old traditions and the
big thing is it's not as populated as
other states in the US and there was a
lottery there is a lottery and they used
to think it was kind of charming people
want to play the lottery okay and
that'll be fun for them the chances of
winning are very very small
extraordinarily small almost everyone
who ever plays ever loses and I used to
think it was benign or not any big deal
but I have changed my mind about that
over the last 30 years the lottery is
mostly a tax on people who don't know
math and the reason they don't know math
is because people like me have failed to
enlighten people on what it really means
when it's one and two hundred and thirty
million
it means you will lose that's what it
means if you have a one and 230 million
chance of winning it means you will lose
and when I was doing stand-up comedy I
used to have a joke a joke about having
a revolver a gun where the bullets are
arranged in a circle I don't know your
ancestor Yuri but you might be from one
of the Eastern Bloc countries in Europe
and we have an expression in the United
States Russian roulette where there's
one bullet in the gun and you spin it
and then you hold it to your head and
see whether or not you'll die and that's
a one in six chance traditionally but in
the lottery it's one and two hundred
thirty million or four hundred and fifty
million so imagine a gun with four
hundred forty nine million nine hundred
ninety nine thousand nine hundred
nine bullets in it and one empty chamber
you would not hold that to your head
for two dollars ever and so I feel bad
that the people who play the lottery are
generally people with lower education
and lower incomes these are statistical
facts so we are accidentally taxing
people who can least afford it and it's
frustrating for me as a science educator
so my advice to you is don't play the
lottery use your dollars for something
else and if you do play the lottery
understand you get some pleasure out of
it but keep in mind you almost always
lose and wait there's more to it that it
preys on this other aspect of human
nature where we embrace the successes
and forget about the losses this is how
psychics make their living palm readers
and so on that you remember when they
accidentally said the right thing and
you forget when they said dozens of
wrong things so people win they bet a
dollar and they win a five dollar
lottery ticket five dollar reward they
almost always reinvest that five dollars
are the four dollars to buy more lottery
tickets it's really it's it seems like a
cool idea and now in the United States
there's huge state incomes based on
lotteries but in the biggest sense it is
a tax on the people who can least afford
it it's frustrating I'm frustrated thank
you for asking that question Airy
Oh